what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have a pretty interesting air
quotes here leak i've been covering
spider-man no way home since before we
even knew the title i've been covering
this for a very long time calling it
spider-man 3 back in the day and i've
never come across such an interestingly
weird way to find out a bit of
information about the movie now i do
have two leaks to talk about today the
first one bear with me it's really funny
and the second one is a pretty serious
one one pointing us and the direction
even more that toby maguire and andrew
garfield will indeed be in spiderman no
way home which of course if you've been
following my channel i 100 believe they
are going to be in the film but i know
people like to get more confirmation so
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on all spider-man news and mcu news so
this first part is just kind of
incredibly funny it's probably the most
clever marketing that i've seen and it
actually comes from domino's pizza their
official australian account now even if
this isn't legit it's certainly funny as
heck take a look at this they posted
this a handful of days ago on their
official instagram page it's a job
application form and on it it says name
toby m experience pizza delivery
photography applying for delivery expert
and the caption for the post reads
received this application yesterday but
had to reschedule the interview
something about a multiverse i don't
know
pizza time now i don't know if this is
just some intern running the instagram
and he decided to post this i don't know
if it's something that they came up with
their own or if they actually have some
sort of a partnership with sony but
either way it's freaking clever and gold
and it's funny how they actually and
specifically mention toby maguire and
the multiverse especially with the
trailer having recently come out again
this is something that i just found
really funny i'm not sure domino's know
something that the whole entire world
doesn't at this point but really kudos
to them this is very clever now on to a
more serious matter there have been some
photos of tobey maguire with tom holland
and a photo of andrew garfield that
looks to be in the same background
circulating the internet recently these
are different than the ones that i saw
the other day those are still on my
twitter but the background does appear
to be the same it's a blue screen a huge
room covered with a blue screen and it
looks to be somewhat of a chaotic scene
and it apparently points to all three
spider-man being together with toby and
tom in one shot now there was talks
about whether or not this was fake and i
would post them on here but it looks
like they are real and they've been
getting taken down and accounts have
been suspended because they were posting
the pictures of course i really want to
show them to you but i can't have my
channel get taken away or any of my
twitter instagram being taken away
either if you simply search them online
you can find them if they haven't
already been all taken down but that is
the main point here they are actually
taking them down if they were fake it
wouldn't matter they wouldn't be taking
them down but since they are it looks
like they are real this actually reminds
me of a time where i posted a plot leak
for wonder woman 1984 and warner
brothers copy strike me for it now
luckily they were cool and they dropped
the strike but when the movie came out
it turns out that the plot league was
100 accurate so companies really only do
this when the leaked things are actually
real so again this is just another sign
that toby maguire and andrew garfield
are going to show up in spider-man no
way home i know there's still some
doubters out there and i totally get it
you won't be convinced until you see it
on screen but at this point there really
is a lot pointing towards this and again
i've been told that they're in the film
by my sources and unless a crazy amount
of reliable people in the industry are
wrong they're in it and we're in for a
wild ride when spider-man no way home
comes out so drop your thoughts about
this in the comments down below let me
know what you think about this domino's
post because it really really cracked me
up don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you